the whole reason these kids got into
trouble was because of us
we can't let them suffer because of our
issues
the only way to end this is by working
together
so what do you say
[Music]
go get it i can't walk even with the
surgery i might never be able to quit
never can't was it just words that are
meaningless it's time for you to get out
of that bed and do something
the end of season two was very painful
for me uh as the actor and
as playing johnny just that wait a
minute
so everything we built in cobra kai is
now
handed over to crease and now i'm out
the door it was this as a
actor you know you just felt this
emptiness and then this beach
moment where he gives up cobra kai and
now he's kind of a man on his own trying
to figure it out outside
i loved it though i mean i absolutely
love coming into that fresh and
and in a sense johnny is shedding the
cobra kai's skin
he's evolving and that's a thrilling
thing to play i loved all the stuff you
know um
him finding his his inner sensei with
miguel and
and putting his heart forward and and
now improvising and figuring it out and
finding his new style and coming up with
his new badass name and
the shoulder to shoulder with daniel and
even though that has a hiccup
you know they just have some things
between them but um
all of that was thrilling to play you
know and i put on a new
a new shirt new new new dojo and
all that um i loved it i loved every
minute of it and um
i'm excited that it's finally out your
student disgraced me
i have been dishonored all because of
him whatever happened i apologize
apology will not give me back my honor
oh neither will this
well yeah i listen karate kid part two
we made
uh in hawaii for the most part all the
exteriors and uh
the beauty of what happens in kobe kai
this year is i got to go to okinawa with
yuji okamoto
the the karate in part two was the
wonderful thing about that
film is you dove into miyagi's
world when the russo through the eyes of
a teenager got to experience a different
culture
so we got to see this different culture
but then we got to see this
rivalry and how it was born back in the
day
between sato and miyagi and this other
other world you had the beautiful and
talented
tamlin tamita who is just spectacular
then and now and eugene and his
character that was such
a dark nemesis for larusso i mean
you know being picked on by the cobra
kai in the valley was one thing but
being in another country and being hated
by
a rival is another and it led to the
fight for the death
so the stakes were just higher uh
in part two now having the opportunity
to
uh reconnect with those two wonderful
characters
and and in kobukai season three
dive into areas of knowledge about
miyagidou and knowledge about mr miyagi
that luruso never knew
and therefore our audience our cobra
thai audience and the karate kid fans
have never known
um is great way to inform characters
going forward
and that's yeah though really does well
and i'm super proud of those
those scenes and those moments and the
fact that we got to uh
shoot a little bit in okinawa it was
sort of as close as i could get to have
the spirit of pat morita and miyagi in
in
in our show what are you tango in cash
i know tango and cash were narcotics
detectives oh i'm sorry
you do realize neither one of you are
cops right
you know they both have the same mission
but two completely different styles and
ways of going about things
so that's you know they're heading in
the same direction but they're peeling
apart at the same time you know
johnny instigating everything and it was
really fun to
you know to be in the car and know that
we're we're going to go and do something
together you know that was a great
feeling i love that you know and
you know of course the coronets fall
down and then you know
and his wife calls and all that that fun
stuff and then going and doing the fight
the idea of going against the bad guys
with daniel was fun and then the way it
flips
and as soon as he pulls me off somebody
now it's back on between the two of us
and we're going at it
i mean what a blast you know when i read
that it was like that's awesome you know
um filming that was really tricky uh we
didn't have a lot of time and there's a
lot of
a lot of bodies flying around so the
actual filming of that scene was
was brutally hot and we had a few hours
to make that happen with a big stunt
team
and a lot of coverage and in fact this
the fight is actually
was choreographed even bigger than what
you see it was just what we could get
was there
um but then yeah then then the cool off
period of that where
you know where we we both push each
other and now we realize we're fighting
each other and then the
boom it's right back again you know and
you know
look at miguel look at you look at
robbie you're a bad dad you're a bad
sensei yeah you're a real great teacher
get my car back that's freaking great
writing man yeah
i love that scene it was fun it was done
in pieces i
my favorite stuff of that is once the
fight's over
you know once it's like you're crazy no
you're crazy
yeah well you should and then when we
each take jabs at each other
yeah well look what happened to robbie
and then daniel comes back to
you know i forget what his line was but
it was a real low blow to
johnny and then you feel that they both
feel bad for saying that to each other
and that's a level that we hadn't seen
before you know even when he says you
better bring that car back to the
dealership and the tag
you know it's it's just like that's
what's important like
[Music]
you know and and so there's a level in
johnny and daniel
there that we haven't seen in the
previous you know 21 episodes
that uh will continue going forward but
they can't get out of their own way a
lot of times and
they're each other's kryptonite if you
will out of nowhere the guy's
sucker-punching
what an [ __ ] i know man
what a thrill man i mean you know to to
get to go do that and walk the same kind
of thing and patterns and she's fun man
i love lisa she's just
she's just so natural and easy and we
just it was just picking up
right where we left off so many years
ago saying goodbye on the set of the
karate kid it was that long ago and i
bumped into her over the years to have
her back and to have
to watch her you know she's she's a lot
like like ally but she's really she's
lisa you know but she created this alley
character
and to watch it fall on her again and
to me embodied johnny again and
to get to say the lines the writers
wrote between the two of us it was
really really special you know from the
date
the lunch date to the golf and stuff um
you know the bubble gum stuff on the
ferris wheel and you know i mean and she
she packs a punch man she
even in karate kid when we did that
scene in the uh the country club where
daniel gets spaghetti on him and i laugh
and she punched me she was the only
person in the karate kid the entire
movie that actually connected with me
with a punch was elizabeth's shoe every
single time
she couldn't pull her punch you know and
then we're we're getting that stuffed
animal
and you know just at the golf and stuff
and she'd jam that thing into me man and
i'm like gosh you're tough
anyway it was fantastic i loved her um
and loved the character love how it fit
and love what she is between daniel and
johnny and
how she propels the story and that she's
alive on the show it was
fantastic listen it was talk about you
know just talk about from the get-go
from the first
pitch days you know it was about you
know getting there and when would be the
right time and it was really you know
that rests in the lap of john josh and
hayden our creators
they were trying to find uh the best
place to do this and and they wanted it
to be
i think uh the end of season three they
certainly teed it up
at the end of season two um it's teed up
throughout the series from when the two
guys are at the bar and
and then looking at pictures on the the
facebook fortunately
just like everything else with this
franchise it somehow comes together
and uh and in a beautiful way and it was
wonderful to have her
in the show the fans are gonna go insane
i i think they're gonna love it and it
was great for
us you know everyone or
be it um you know the kobakai actors
that are
the og cobra kai guys or or randy heller
who plays my mom or
tamlin and yuji and uh any of the folks
that have come back from the original
just bring such an
a-game to the series and it's such a
you know it's just a type of history and
connection
that we all share and um elizabeth
hugh's role in this is a little bit
of you know opening up the eyes of these
two guys who can't see past their [ __ ]
a lot of times and uh she has certain
intentions i think with johnny and
then and then by seeing everything she
makes her choices as to how to further
their
stories and and yet it's got all the
nostalgia you would want so i think it's
it's it's going to be a nice
thing going forward
it's it's all in everything uh you
you could imagine i mean listen and and
youtube
stepped up uh from the get-go and did a
a great job in
and launching the show and you know 100
on rotten tomatoes i mean come on
you know uh so it's been a super
positive there
and uh but this was there was a while uh
we didn't know if we had a home
and we had completed season three and
then i think google
mandated to youtube out of the uh
original scripted world it was just the
business choice they made
and then we were hit with a global
pandemic and
uh we're all still dealing with that for
sure but
it was like how do you move this now and
you know we wound up where we
initially wanted to be but it's kind of
uh
perfect it's like having your an awesome
out of town tryout
and now you're on broadway or you know
you played in the grapefruit league and
now you're at yankee stadium
so or whatever is is a parallel but it's
been
an awesome embrace around the world and
we are just
it's just amazing
oh [ __ ] that's all right you felt like a
champ
you know i think overall the arc of
miguel is one that
resembles kind of like a roller coaster
i think uh you know when you first meet
him he's someone who really
doesn't know where he fits in doesn't
really know
he doesn't have uh kind of his own voice
set yet
and through karate and really through
johnny he's able to
you know get some confidence instilled
in him and how it kind of goes overboard
and really he takes a little bit too
much to heart
and we see that at the end of season one
and at the end of season two so
so going into season three i'm sure
it'll be the same kind of rollercoasters
of emotions
one of the harder uh moments
for you know hawk it is
you know at the sort of the beginning of
his arc but it's in season
two yeah where you know it's a flashback
to eli
um you know super distraught about
getting bullied
um i think that that was kind of a i was
bullied a lot i was a kid and it's
something i very much just like i forget
about and it was just kind of like weird
to
like bring that stuff up and like
remember
like similar conversations with my
parents um
so that that was kind of hard but uh i'm
really really happy with the way it came
out and i love
you know all the backstory that they've
you know given the character and
i think probably some of the most fun
i've had is in season three when i'm
when i'm fighting
brooks uh at the dojo when all the you
know big buff
jocks come in that's probably some of
the most fun i've had and
you know it's a really fun fight but
it's also a pretty emotionally charged
moment uh and so that was something that
was
really really fun to do is sort of like
let loose on this
pad and just punch the crap out of it
was
awesome it was really really fun i
thought we were the good guys
i think the mid-season of season three
is really fun for me
because uh we called that dark sam
that's how we referred to her we were
like all right dark sam's around the
corner
dark sam got eyeliner dark sam got
darker nails
dark sam got to learn the beau staff so
i was you know super into that whole
idea of like
samantha like in her recovery process
maybe asking herself well like is it so
bad to be bad
and maybe i need to take the reins and
maybe that's how you win in life
and you know like trying to apply those
those thoughts to yourself i had a lot
of fun with that
um and like the flip side of the coin
it was also the most challenging season
for me in terms of
uh character arc because of kind of
where
that like you know in order to be at a
place where you could push yourself to
such levels of
anger and frustration and sam initiates
a fight that's the first time she comes
in there and she's like i'm not gonna
let somebody punch first i'm gonna punch
first
i'm gonna strike first and so that was
you know a big deal for me but in order
to get to that place especially for
somebody like samantha
takes quite a big push so it took a lot
of the emotional side which was
uh challenging and fun in a different
way
because i got to like you know stretch
myself out a little bit
like you know acting wise but uh
was definitely challenging like the
specifically episode five the
the panic attack mid fight uh was
was challenging because i wanted to get
it right
it looks to me like you taught me
everything you knew let us find out
[Music]
you